alors tito
beaucoup de mails que je reçois rapporte
un comportement un petit peu délictueux
dans les villes de la tournée est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à vous repentir oui
interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
titoff oui quand j'étais petit as tu
essayé de regarder sous le bureau de la
maîtresse pour voir sa culotte
ouais
mais justement c'était ça le problème
c'est qu'on voyait que la culotte en
fait titoff as-tu enfermer des élèves de
sexe féminin
dans les cabinets mais ça donc je le
faisais pas petit mais maintenant
j'essaye des fois d'enfermer les galas
dans les chiottes est ce que tu te
repenti tough sur sa non mais tu
montreras pas au paradis ah merde
titeuf véhicules récemment
as-tu utiliser ta notoriété
pour obtenir des avantages particuliers
oui pour la cause à sa place une wag
grave grave je les gagne en boîte mais
comme sahin carré viiip je regarde
jamais la jeune fille coucou à tout le
monde grave grave je m'éclate et tu
obtiens les avantages particuliers mais
là déjà ça rien qu'à faire le guet c'est
super quoi et tu t'en reprend bien sûr
obiwi 40 de toit fuyante titov dans ces
cas là as-tu exigé de tes partenaires
des pratiques contre nature
contre nature non jamais jamais et qu'on
titoff ces actes délictueux ont ils
étaient accompagnés par l'absorption de
substances illicites way jamais
jamais titoff oui dans ces cas là quand
tu as pris ces substances tu ne
t'appartient plus
il m'appartient
pick up oui parce que tu as pris ces
substances illicites tu ne t'appartient
plus est ce que tu penses que l'on
puisse aimer une femme
et la tâche et la foule était
justement passé parce qu'on aime si on
fait ça si tu veux entrer au paradis
titeuf dis moi maintenant je me repens
je me repens
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu